we're skipping over consciousness and
other animals and going to innovation at
the margins of the ancestors wisdom this
again from undergathers guide to the
21st century
during the peopling of the new world
when was relying on consciousness more
effective than relying on culture under
what circumstances are cultural rules
more trustworthy
as the nez pearce or their ancestors
moved into the range of camus and death
camus they were looking for food in an
increasingly unfamiliar landscape the
staples they had come to know were their
cultural standbys as those familiar
foods became harder to source innovation
became ever more necessary they were
reaching the limits of their ancestors
wisdom and confronting a puzzle for
which the best tool was consciousness
as the people move across space it is
relatively easy to notice as the
ancestor's wisdom becomes less
applicable as the people move through
time however as we all do elders may not
recognize their wisdom becoming out of
date the young see it it is no accident
that those who are coming of age in
times of change push boundaries and that
language and norms change somewhat with
each generation
throughout history the ancestors wisdom
has generally remained relevant long
enough for new generations to get their
footing to know what needs to be pushed
against
as a people move through time that is
changing extremely rapidly however as
our world is now it is more difficult to
know what to do with the increasing
irrelevancy of the ancestors wisdom and
with what to replace it
the margins of the ancestor's wisdom are
rarely hard and fast at those margins
wherever they are it is time to niche
switch
consider three broad contexts in which
humans have learned and innovated in
times past
the first is the utterly new idea the
idea that springs to mind often unbidden
and without explanation
this was the territory that the first
mayan mesopotamian and chinese people
were in when they innovated farming
similarly the innovation of the wheel
metallurgy and pottery before those
things existed nobody knew they were
possible
the second context in which innovation
occurs is when you know that something
is possible on the basis that it's been
done before but you have no idea how to
make it happen
the wright brothers saw flight in other
organisms and felt confident that it
could be accomplished by machine
third and finally you might have
instruction you know what you're
shooting for and have someone or some
set of rules or instructions telling you
how
between school and youtube we often
conflate this third kind of learning for
the only kind of learning that is
possible
the third type of learning is the most
cultural it is the learning of perceived
wisdom in contrast humans are at our
most conscious and therefore are most
innovative in the first two contexts
when the status quo when the status quo
is no longer sufficient we must seek to
innovate to push beyond how it's always
been done
the status quo is an inherent tension
the status quo is in inherent tension
with our unique insights those ideas
that we have deep at night are often
syntheses reflecting the pulling
together of common threads into uncommon
meaning
so these three contexts and you know
this
everything this book does tie together
as as diverse and broad as the book is
but you're talking about the three
broadly three different ways that humans
can learn
and just making explicit that school and
now youtube and many people will be
surprised to find us lumping youtube
with school but youtube and school
especially the youtube videos that
provide direct instruction for you know
how to do a thing
are a very explicit
modern
cultural
mode of conveying information that
allows for very little freedom and
innovation and consciousness
well actually you know i think it's
important to realize that school is
necessary in some sense but it is
inherently if done right a supplement to
the majority of learning which is not
best done
in school so for example and
i think the example that makes this
clearest is
nobody needs to put you in school to
teach you how to talk
right teaching
teaching you how to talk is something
that happens automatically if you're if
your ears and your mind are healthy at
birth we can't even stop you from
learning to talk you'll pick it up out
of the air and very probably your
parents
are programmed to be unable to resist
the things that will help you do it like
babbling back at a child it's very hard
not to babble back at a child what you
heard them say right now think about it
the way you sound to yourself inside
your head is very different from what
other people hear so how useful is it to
have somebody tell you oh here's what i
heard you just say right it's a feedback
right
so anyway the point is
yeah it's uh it's a way to allow the
child to error correct right exactly
it's not mockery it's it's a a root into
i mean it's it is it is training theory
of mind it is it is it again requires
theory of mind i heard you say this i
heard you say this right and oh my god
it meant this to me you said ball now
maybe i didn't mean to say ball but if
you then break out a ball and you're all
excited i get the sense that this object
and what i just said and your reaction
are all somehow tied together maybe i'll
try to trigger that cool thing again you
know
so um anyway we don't have to put you in
school to teach you to talk right in
fact or walk
right well right because again the
parent offspring system is built to to
make this happen
we do need to put you in school or
something very like it at least we need
formal training to teach you to read and
write
and the reason for this is pretty
obvious at least in retrospect it's that
speaking are very very ancient they're
going to go back at least several
hundred thousand years and more likely a
million or more what what are speaking
oh um reading writing what
speaking r speaking r yeah okay speaking
r um
reading and writing go back a maximum of
something like 8 000 years and for most
people they would have been a non-issue
until very late like the recent several
hundred years and so the point is
evolution hasn't had the chance to build
the mechanism that you automatically
acquire this just by looking at the
symbols in your world so i mean i
we we have this argument in the book and
i agree with it and yet you know maybe
for the first time hearing you talk
about it here i had this thought of like
i don't know how much formal schooling i
needed
um i was you know i was so driven to the
written world and you know you and i
have such different brains in this
regard i was so i i i talked late you
know more completely rather than in
single words and i read early and that
was just where i was driven to go and
sure i had the same kind of parental
feedback as you were talking about with
regard to walking and talking but that
happened um before school and yeah you
know for many for many people it it is a
matter of direct instruction although
frankly so much of how direct
instruction takes place is destructive
of the desire to keep learning right i'm
not arguing that school itself is
necessary but the formalism of this is
an alphabet right these are the letters
in it this is the sequence in which they
come these are the yeah i'm not i'm
actually i'm not sure like i think i
think that that is
that is the way it is taught and that's
not the way that some of us learned it
we sort of we were walking around doing
you know sort of picking symbols out of
our universe going like oh that i see
that other people look at that and are
making meaning from it just like you're
talking about with regard to um spoken
language i believe the motivation would
be there but i don't believe that you
would the amount of arbitrariness in an
alphabet and the way
alphabetic symbols are put together into
words and the at least in english right
but the variation of the pronunciation
of those phonemes and all of that you
need somebody to be the one to clue you
into the underlying arbitrary
associations before you can begin to put
them together with the stuff that you
already have on board which is the
spoken word right so you know that there
is a word for duck right and then the
arbitrary symbols have sounds and then
those sounds come together and it's like
ah that's the overarching symbol for
duck i meant this this is interesting i
actually i really do think you have a
model in your head that's not a match
for what some of us experience i don't
you know the the idea of like pieces
that come together it's like
not necessarily i don't i don't think
this is the place to get mired down but
i i do think that um
that
those of us who are very driven to and
seek out and always want to have sort of
written word in front of us are are
probably likely and at least anecdotally
in my case were not people who were
doing like you know phoneme let's see
what it sounds like when you put it
together it was much more like and we're
in and we're doing like yeah but
i i it's interesting to me that we have
a disagreement here you have to be able
to say
daddy what's this symbol right oh that's
a d right in order to get to the word in
order to get to the meaning of the word
and so the idea i think what
the upshot of what you're arguing is
that some people would learn to read
even if nobody clued them into the
meaning of
the arbitrary symbols in the alphabet
and i don't i don't believe that anybody
would pick it up from exposure to those
things
that effectively literacy requires
formalism
whereas the ability to speak does not
and it's you know it's a little bit like
um
you know it's almost exactly like
reading music too right musicality does
not require reading music but if you're
going to go into if you're going to be
musically literate in that same sense
then somebody has to clue you into the
schema in order to to pick it up but
anyway well certainly i mean that that
that is a better match for my experience
with with music having been sort of
introduced to both playing music and
reading music both
very young and almost simultaneously and
they were you know they were both highly
formalized processes
um but anyway the point is
we
a a hunter-gatherer child does not go to
school and it does not mean that they
are uneducated it means that they are
built such that their environment
educates them without the need for the
formalism and the farther you get from
an environment that educates you
naturally i mean even think about
walking down the street right the fact
that there is a line at the edge of the
sidewalk where things go from very safe
to extremely dangerous that's a very
arbitrary odd thing and you're not so it
sounds like you're talking about a line
drawn and sometimes it is but really
you're talking about a uh
a physical feature of the universe that
is a border um called the curb yeah it
can be either but i think the point is
the six-inch drop at the curb does not
begin to tell you about the hazard that
starts there it's a tall curb
i think that's a really tall curb yeah
okay i don't know i mean
in our in our neighborhood there are
lots of places where there isn't even a
cure but just the idea that you're
paying attention to some
line and that the you know
the forces generated on one side of that
line are so many thousands of times
greater than the forces generated on the
other side that it's a whole different
model that applies
right that's a that's a kind of of you
know that's not the natural world being
logically deducible that's arbitrary
stuff right and you know some formalism
is necessary in all those cases
yeah um but
uh so anyway so yeah school is necessary
but it's a supplement and we tend to as
you were reading we tend to think of
school as the way in which learning is
done and in fact this becomes perfectly
absurd if you if you think about
watching
uh
an expert rock climber
right
and you think about
learning how it is that they ascend
something like el capitan
you can know a hell of a lot about how
you climb el capitan without knowing the
first thing about
doing it learn better rock climbing
right learn better yeah you can learn
all sorts of things right now just i
don't remember who said it but you know
this this famous advice to people trying
to learn tennis from a tennis pro you
know play better tennis right where in
fact what you really need is somebody
who plays better tennis than you to keep
returning the ball and putting it at
different corners challenging you in
unexpected ways right you don't you
don't learn when you're super
comfortable you're not going to learn
maximally when you're super comfortable
and frankly a lot of modern schooling as
much as it feels ridiculous and deeply
uncomfortable to people is effectively a
dulling experience like we're just going
like you can sit down you don't have to
move too much you don't have to go
outside of your expected bounds you know
you know when you sit here you're gonna
today it's history and you know that's
not where you're gonna learn the most
you're gonna learn the most it's like oh
we're out you know we're up playing
frisbee and now we're gonna now we're
gonna start talking about history or you
know or we're in the rain forest and
we're gonna start talking about the
history of you know the the rubber
industry in the amazon or whatever it is
this is gonna come it the lessons that
come at the unexpected moments and and
throw you
are are where you are likely to learn
the most yeah absolutely
so um we do have i do want to share one
more excerpt from
from the book but i also wanted to
because this chapter is about this
tension between culture and
consciousness we have talked about
and uh we also talk about and i think
this is maybe in the final excerpt
that being analogous to that the tension
between the sacred and the shamanistic
the sacred being a sort of a reification
of the orthodoxy of the received wisdom
of therefore the culture and the
shamanistic being an analogy for that
which is chaotic that which is
unexpected that which is where
innovation happens most of which is
going to be probably useless some of
which might even be dangerous but that's
where the innovation is going to happen
it's it's by analogy to what goes on in
the genome where some things are
extremely resistant to mutation and
therefore very slow to change and
there's a very good reason that you
would do that there's certain things
that if you upend them cancel the whole
project and so they get special
protection from change so sacred in
cultural space is that which is heavily
protected from change because
change tends to be very disruptive
and then there are other things that are
prone to change things like the immune
system
needs to be able to update its model of
uh hazards
you know even within a lifetime and so
there's a sort of uh
overdrive for uh mutation and so our
point is that you've got these two
things both within you know we
deliberately describe them in this
uh religious framework but the idea is
it's not that religion
is this stodgy force religion has both
of these components because of course
religions are compendiums of wisdom that
lineages need and so they need in order
to be compendiums of wisdom they have to
be able to bootstrap new wisdom how do
you do that well it starts out in the
shamanistic and then that which works
gets driven into the sacred and gets
protected
from change and you know it's not that
the sacred doesn't change but the point
is it changes slowly because because of
the hazard of unintended consequences
[Music]
you